[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur TVfil 78 si
vous venez tout juste de nous rejoindre
il est l'heure du journal de la
rédaction voici les principaux titres
qui seront développés éducation
l'application des nouveaux rythmes
scolaires rencontre de plus en plus
d'opposition malgré la présentation
d'assouplissement par Benoît Amond des
communes refus de s'y soumettre dès
septembre nous irons à morpa mais aussi
à Plaisir l'association rire pour guérir
organise son galat annuel à poissie le
16 mai une association qui a décidé
d'apporter l'humour à ceux qui vivent
des moments difficiles la présidente de
l'association et l'invité de cette
édition nouveau volet également de notre
série dédié à l'Europe dans notre
quotidien nous verrons l'implication de
l'Union dans la réalisation des produits
manufacturés on débute avec ces quelques
images à la prison de bois d'Arc
l'établissement pénitentiare était
bloqué tout ce matin par le personnel
qui dénonce le manque de moyens il
manquerait selon eux 400 surveillants
dans la région et le nombre de détenus
battrait des records 836 dans cette
ville des Yvelines pour seulement 501
places le mouvement de contestation qui
touche l'ensemble de la France les
gardiens de prison ont été reçus par la
ministre de la Justice Christiane tobira
qui rappelle vient un communiqué que 33
millions ont déjà été investis ces
derniers mois on ferme tout le monde
toutes les personnes qui rentrent pas
dans le moule sauf qu'à moment donné les
les prisons c'est des cocottes minutes
le couvert commence à soulever vous avez
des incidents qui se sont passés à Réo à
ce que à LAN sur Sart des prises d'utage
à Laon et fait tout ça mais ça ça
devient une ça devient notre quotidien
Aujourd'hui la prison n'a pas de sens
parce que Ben vous avez des détenus qui
restent allongés dans leur lit jusqu'à
11h du matin parce qu'ils sont inoccupés
on a ils veulent pas participer aux
activités il y a aucune obligation la
réforme des rythmes scolaires qui passe
mal la nouvelle mouture présentée par le
nouveau ministre de l'Éducation Benoît
amont a reçu un avis négatif ce lundi du
Conseil supérieur de l'éducation
certaines mairies n'hésite plus à braver
la loi et décréter qu'elles ne mettront
pas en place la réforme en septembre
c'est le cas de la ville de Plaisir
Catherine
zulato élu en mars maire de plaisir
Joséphine colmasberger imprime sa marque
de manière forte elle ne fera pas
appliquer la réforme des rythmes scolair
en septembre prochain son argumentaire
est d'abord financier cela coûterait
741000 € par an à la commune trop cher
nous ça nous demande 25 personnes
supplémentaires sur la ville à
pleintemps c'est pas possible he quel
choix prenons-nous j'augmente les impôts
a priori il en est pas question puisque
je crois que les gens en ont vraiment
assez maintenant des augmentations
d'impôts je fais quoi je supprime des
professeurs au Conservatoire j'enlève
des berceaux dans les crèches
franchement là ça me met un dilemme très
important et pourtant ce n'était pas
faute d'avoir fait le travail pendant un
an et demi la concertation a été menée à
plaisir des ateliers de travail ont été
constitués et même une proposition a été
présentée à l'Inspection Académique la
maire UMP se met donc hors la loi et
regrette qu'une concertation plus large
n'it pas été menée avec les communes sur
plaisir nous avons 29 écoles je pense
qu'on sait de quoi on parle au niveau de
la gestion des écoles donc on aurait dû
je pense au niveau national prendre des
villes dans de certaines strates et
commencer à faire un espèce de brouillon
pour voir comment ça allait se passer et
ensuite prendre des décisions
aujourd'hui je ne rentre pas dans une
guerre contre je dirais cette le
gouvernement ou contre cette loi comme
ça de façon primaire parce que c'est pas
du tout mon tempérament je suis très
légaliste et je trouve ça très
dommageable d'être obligé de dire que je
ne pourrais pas je ne peux pas ça veut
pas dire que c'est un point de non
retour ça veut dire simplement que pour
la rentrée 2014 la ville de Plaisir
n'appliquera pas les rythmes scolaires
du côté des parents d'élèves rencontré
ce lundi après-midi aux abords de
l'école Fournier un certain soulagement
est-ce qu'elle peut ne
pas ne pas l'appliquer quoi je suis
contente personnellement parce que ça
m'arrangeait pas du du tout au niveau de
mes horaires de travail et horaires
d'école donc pour moi c'est une bonne
décision la coupure du milieu de semaine
elle est quand même pas négligeable sans
lui emboîter le pas d'autres communes à
droite montre des signes d'opposition à
cette réforme à encour un moratoire
d'application a été demandé pour la
rentrée 2014 même cas de figure à MPa
d'autres villes à gauche cette fois sont
favorables à la réforme à Guill encour
par exemple le cadrage des rythmes
scolaires a été validé en décembre à
manilamo la concertation se poursuit
entre les services et les enseignants la
ville s'est déclarée favorable à la
réforme les communes ont jusqu'au 6 juin
pour déposer leur dossier et l'undice
c'est le responsable de l'inspection
académique des zvelines qui s'exprimera
dans ce journal on parle à présent des
européennes encore une vingtaine de
jours avant le scrutin Europe Écologie
Les ver est en pleine campagne en
île-de-fance et les têtes de liste
viennent de faire escale dans les
Yvelines sur le plateau de sacly
objectif défendre les terres agricoles
face au projet de l'opération d'intérêt
national Olivier maniscal et
jonathanillman les vers au secours de la
terre le 5 mai dans le cadre de la
campagne pour les européennes 2014 les
candidats Île-de-France d'Europe
Écologie se mobilisaient sur le plateau
de sa clé futur chantier du Grand Paris
car pour bâtir la prochaine silicone
vallée à la française 350 hactares de
terre cultivé vont être utilisés sur les
2700 hactares actuellement disponies des
terres pourtant d'une grande fertilité
dont la qualité est reconnue sur le
territoire français gros travail sous
1,20 d'umus il y a une couche d'argile
assez épaisse qui retient l'eau et donc
ces terres n'ont pas besoin d'être
arrosé même pour le maïs même en période
de sécheresse on l'a vu en 2003 le maïs
s développé
avec une sans sans nécessité d'apport
d'eau alors que c'était le cas dans dans
tout le reste des terres de de France
situé à une vingtaine de kilomètres de
Paris ces Terre pourrait servir selon
les écologistes à nourrir la capitale et
sa petite couronne qui importe
aujourd'hui à 98% ses produits agricoles
une situation qui indigne les défenseurs
de l'environnement pour moi l'idée que
cette terre agricole merveilleuse une
des meilleures au monde va devenir un
stade de rugby des parkings pour des
supermarchés ou même des campus pour des
grandes écoles qui ont déjà des locaux
qui demandent pas du tout à déménagers
je trouve que c'est emblématique d'une
absence de compréhension du du monde
dans lequel nous vivons et de
l'importance de la terre qui nous
nourrit avec ces terre cédé au Grand
Paris les écologistes craignent
forcément un appauvrissement de
l'agriculture périurbaine pourtant
dynamique en île-de-fance un
appauvrissement qui obligerait les
agriculteurs à vendre et concéder de
nouveaux terrains à
l'urbanisation en 2009 Europe Écologie
l'v était arrivé 2e du scrutin en
Île-de-France europeope toujours demain
ce sont les têtes de liste socialiste en
Île-de-France qui seront au Mureau pour
un meeting per vanche BZ et Guillaume
Balas seront à la salle des habitants
avenus de la République nous aurons bien
évidemment l'occasion d'en reparler
nouveau poet à présent de notre série
l'Europe et vous chaque soir jusqu'à la
veille du scrutin nous nous intéressons
avec le Centre d'information Europe
Direct Eveline sur l'importance de
l'Union dans notre quotidien ce soir les
produits
manufacturés le label CE est un label
créé par la Commission européenne et qui
vise tout simplement à euh favoriser à
commercialiser les produits dans l'Union
européenne ce label c'est un garanti de
sécurité alors tout simplement en fait
c'est que si les produits veulent
pouvoir bénéficier de ce label ils
doivent répondre à certaines exigences
alors de manière très simple par exemple
les peluches pour les enfants si euh si
ces peluches veulent obtenir le label CE
euh notamment lorsque c'est des peluches
qui sont rembourrés en mousse ces
mousses ces mousses doivent passer des
tests de en fait on y met feu et on
regarde la manière dont c'est consumé et
donc si notamment en fait si ça ne
dégage pas de fumée toxique si euh si la
prise de feu est ralentie le produit va
pouvoir obtenir le label CE et donc on a
ainsi sur toute une gamme assez variée
de produits donc ça va du produit
chimique à l'imprimante au téléphone
voilà vraiment une gamme de produits
très larges qui obéissent euh à ce qui
sont régis par ce label CE légalement on
a une garantie de 2 ans donc euh on
connaît tous la garantie d'un an donc si
on a un produit qui est cassé donc on le
renvoit en service aprèsvente et
celui-là est réparé et mais en fait on a
aussi une deuxème année de garantie donc
là ça porte plus sur les vis cachés et
les défauts qui sont qui était innéant
lors de la lors de la construction du du
produit mais il faut savoir donc que
cette deuxè année de garantie est
souvent passé sous silence par les
constructeurs il faut par exemple un
exemple très concret Apple le fabricant
d'ordinateur se fait souvent condamné
par des par des tribunaux parce qu'ils
n'ont pas respecté ils n'ont pas informé
leurs clients qu'il existait une deuxème
année de garantie et en fait tout
simplement ce que faisait Apple c'est
qu'il leur revendait leur propre
garantie ça concerne pas tous les
produits c'est principalement les
produits manufacturer les produits
informatiques et je reçois à présent
dans cette édition du 78 lactu Catherine
Péricard bonsoir vous êtes la présidente
de l'association rire pour guérir votre
association qui a décidé d'amener
l'humour dans les hôpitaux les cliniques
du département pour un public qui vit
forcément des moments difficiles le rire
a donc des
thérapeutiques absolument en fait rire
pour guérir est une branche d'une
association qui a une vocation plus
globale qui s'appelle rire
78 et
qui qui qui a en son sein plusieurs
autres modules de d'intervention sur les
ivelines notamment on va voir comment
pour guérir c'est vraimentel
quelque chose qui depuis 2008 nous tient
à cœur et qu'on a mis en place quels
sont les bienfaits du rire c'est
justement notre question du jour au
micro d'éodie moine et de Jonathan
villman on se retrouve juste après en
plateau prê je une convaincu parce que
moi je sors de deux deuil et je je
m'efforce de rigoler vraiment c'est la
meilleure des thérapies ça permet
d'oublier peut-être ce qu'on a et de de
vivre autrement quoi de de se sentir
exister une espèce de
de détente on oublie tout c'est ça me
paraît essentiel j'ai l'impression que
tout le stress s'en va les ennuis on y
pense plus c'est essentiel pour la vie
de tous les jours voilà on peut pas
vivre sans ça prolonge la
vie le rire et c'est bien fait on va
voir dans un instant un reportage sur
votre association mais déjà
expliquez-nous comment se passe le
travail de rire pour guérir alors le le
travail se passe d'abord avec des
professionnels
euh qui sont donc dirigés par Éric
bouverron qui est le directeur
artistique de tout ce que nous
entreprenons au sein de l'association et
justement on met en place des plateaux
on a donc on a cherché les hôpitaux dans
un premier temps les accueils dans les
équipes des hôpitaux des services
justement qui étit intéressé de voir
peut-être que on allait apporter un plus
bon c'est difficile de il y a beaucoup
d'hôpitaux dans les ivelines bon là on
en touche à peu près une quinzaine mais
ça représente aussi un budget alors donc
et nous nous faisons intervenir des
professionnels de vrais professionnels
qui se produisent qui font des
spectacles dans les hôpitaux dans les
cliniques voilà c'est ça alors c'est
facile justement d'amener le rire dans
les hôpitaux vous nous dites il y a
beaucoup d'établissements mais j'imagine
que tous ne sont pas non plus prêt à
vous accueillir il y a des réticences
parfois voil il y a parfois des
réticcences parce que bon les personnels
des services ne comprennent pas alors il
faut qu'on les persuade et qu'on les
invite à venir voir par exemple des
spectacle comme un mot à l'hôpital mot
bon c'est c'est l'hôpital de Versailles
donc c'est c'est très important le
travail qu'on y fait et eux nous ont cru
et nous ont compris dès le départ quoié
dès le départ justement R pour pour
guérir c'est né d'une idée vous vous
êtes dit pourquoi ne pas tenter oui
parce que ça partait au départ on a com
commencer par les plateaux qui existe
toujours l'organisation de
plateau surtout moi ce qui m'intéressait
c'est les petites communes celles qui
ont pas beaucoup de budget qui met aller
vers eux voilà aller vers l'gent après
on a aussi fait d'autres actions sur un
travail par exemple plus spécifique avec
des communes comme les Murau par exemple
où on a travaillé donc avec des jeunes
voilà et puis on s'est dit bon quand
même le rire en hôpital c'est quand même
bien faut qu'on arrive à faire quelque
chose dans les ulines et c'est un projet
que Éric bouverron avait proposé à
Pierre Bédier à l'époque où il était
conseiller général il y a il y a
quelques années et ça lui a tellement
plus que il a dit bon ben je le Conseil
général va vous soutenir et le Conseil
général nous soutient dans ces actions
voilà pourela fonctionne effectivement
il faut des fonds il y a un gala qui
sera organisé 4è gala rire pour guérir à
poiss le AC arm sur scè on en parle dans
un instant juste après ce reportage Deol
Tor qui revient sur votre travail dans
les établissements
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hospitaliers jamais l'un sans l'autre
Christian Gabriel et son singe Freddy se
sont arrêtés il y a quelques jours à
l'hôpital min
du non rigolez pas on n pas là pour
rigoler bon donc je vais vous présenter
Freddy oui permzm la joie oui l'honneur
le
plaisir vous présenter mon personnage
que je demande d'applaudir il est
psychopathe c'est Freddy
ou grand Ventrilo reconnu Christian
Gabriel fait partie des artistes engagés
dans l'association rire 78 créé il y a 7
ans à travers son spectacle les enfants
s'évadent un moment de leur chambre
d'hôpital
ça met un petit peu de gué dans le
service change les idées un peution frdy
je questiond
questiony
Joh rire pour guérir c'est le nom de
cette action et d'après les médecins
l'humour aurait de réel bienfait sur la
santé ah je pense que quand on est en
Phe de maladie chronique ou quand on est
vraiment hpit le fait de rire de pouvoir
se détendre ça peut a ça peut aider
l'enfant à penser à autre chose et
pourquoi pas à mieux guérir c'est
possiblea fontaine allant
promener TR ai clair que je suis
baigné habitué des grands musical et des
cabarets parisiens le duo attache
toujours une importance particulière à
se produire devant ces enfants malades
j'ai pas mal passé de temps dans les
hôpitaux voilà donc les enfants vu un
petit peu la détresse des enfants le
côté un petit peu il reste tout seul
donc donc voilà on dit on va aller les
amuser avec Freddy et et voilà c'est
pour rendre hommage aussi à un artiste
un grand artiste qui nous a quitté qui
s'appelle Bernard girudau qui est un de
mes amis et puis malheureusement quand
il était à l'hôpital on allit voir les
enfants et tout ça et puis je continue
je le faisais avant de le connaître je
continue à le faire et on le fera
toujours quoi le duo ne s'arrête pas là
il sera au centre clinique de
psychothérapie à poissie le 16 mai
prochain rire pour guérriir permettre
aux malades d'oublier leurs difficultés
un instant Catherine percard la
présidente de l'association est donc en
plateau avec nous ce soir on a parlé
tout à l'heure des difficultés parfois à
faire rentrer le rire dans les
établissements hospitaliers avec des
réticences du personnel médical mais
est-ce que les artistes parfois sont
aussi difficiles à convaincre parce que
c'est particulier pour eux de de se
produire devant ce ce type d'audience
euh oui mais c'est pour eux c'est une
bonne gagure quand même parce que c'est
quelque chose qui ne font pas peut-être
d'instinct comme ça il préfèrent faire
peut-être des des plateaux classiques
quoi mais là c'est parce qu'ils sont
généreux vous savez les artistes sont
très généreux et il donne beaucoup je
vois Christian Gabriel qui est un un
grand euh et bien il est venu
spontanément quoi parce qu'on le connaît
on lui a demandé il a dit mais oui bien
sûr je vais donner un peu de et ça
marche bien et le voilà parce que en
plus de ça il faut amener des artistes
qui font tout tous un peu un travail
différent et dans le rire il y a
beaucoup de choses le 16 mai se
déroulera le 4e gala c'est à poissi
c'est pour récolter des fonds et là
c'est important parce que les fonds
c'est le nerf de la guerre comme à
chaque fois alors pouvez nous présenter
un petit peu ce gars là peut-être alors
écoutez c'est un gala qui a été mis en
place il y a plusieurs années avec le
groupe PSA plej qui est toujours été
intéressé pour soutenir cette action
parce qu'on intervient aussi à l'hôpital
de poissie donc c'était important et ils
ont une magnifique salle à poissie qu'
qu'il nous prête dans lequelle on fait
ce garsà alors eux ils invitent donc les
personnels de de l'usine de de poissie H
et puis nous on on remercie ainsi euh
les personnels hospitaliers euh de leur
accueil et du fait que parce qu'il se
donne quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
mal pour pour l'organisation ça
contrarie peut-être un un peu parfois
tous les jours leur leurs actions de
tous les jours quoi et leurs train train
donc c'est aussi pour les remercier quoi
et les coordonnées les renseignements
pratiques si vous souhaitez y assister
qui se sont affichés à l'écran avec
plusieurs artistes il y aura sophie
Forte aussi qui sera présente notamment
lors de de cette soirée le 16 mai il y a
encore des établissements où vous
souhaiteriez vous installer est-ce qu'il
y a encore des projets pour
l'association oui parce que toute
l'année toute l'année on est au contact
avec avec les ben les établissements et
même si là on a à peu près si vous
voulez bouclé jusque jusque juillet
septembre et puis après bon on est en
train d'organiser toute la suite de la
fin de l'année quoi c'est des hôpitaux
qui qui regardent ce soir l'émission il
peuvent vous
contacterment à diff au contraire au
contraire on est très heureux de pouvoir
venir plateau le 16 mai à poissie le
ventrilogue Christian Gabriel qui sera
présent elle également l'humoriste
sophie Forte je vous le disais le
cabaret senchy également Éric Bouvron
qui sera prê
de ce plaué et nous avons un autre
parrain qui est formidable qui est éic
Antoine et qui sera aussi présent et qui
oui j'espère voilà qui devrait également
venir le 16 mai pour ce 4e Gal rire pour
guérir merci Catherine percard d'être
passé notre plateau président de
l'association rire pour guérir santé
toujours et ce nouveau concept à la mode
la proximologie l'étude des relations
entre la personne malade ou dépendante
et ses proches comment cela fonctionne
explication de yolen
Torz
régulièrement pierre reçoit son
thérapeute chez lui au
chaînet voilà alors comment allez-vous
aujourd'hui monsieur
ficouré écoutez on va dire que ça va
lorsqu'il apprend qu'il a un cancer de
la prostate il y a 9 ans ce dentiste
aujourd'hui retraité continue à
travailler jusqu'à son opération pour
surmonter cette épreuve il sent le
besoin de parler d'échanger d'être
rassuré son médecin l'oriente alors vers
ce thérapeute expert en soins de support
oncologique on prend en VIIe on a parlé
beaucoup et puis il m'a fait des
massages quand quand j'étais trop
stressé et trop
tendu et voilà et ça m'a fait du bien
vous savez l'aide psychologique je pense
qu'elle est nécessaire quand même parce
que quand quand ça vous arrive on a beau
dire on a beau prendre sur soi s'affiche
un coup Louis casaz le thérapeute se
rent à domicile mais reçoit aussi
certains patients dans son cabinet à
Paris les patients ce sont les malades
du cancer mais bien souvent leur
entourage a également besoin
d'accompagnement dans 4 mois il
aménagera ses nouveaux locaux chez lui
au chaîné dans les ivelines et plus
généralement en France son métier est
assez peu répandu on parle de
proxyologie le thérapeute vient en
complément des soins médicaux de
l'oncologue avec qui il est en contact
direct le but c'est de donner confiance
à mon patient et qu'il se sente mieux
donc ça va être par le l'échange comme
je disais et par les postures se sentir
bien dans son corps même si on sent son
corps affaibli ou en ou en douleur le
but c'est d'optimiser et de donner
confiance aux patients et surtout de
vivre avec sa maladie le plus important
c'est de vivre ça c'est très important
et les patients à partir du moment on
annonce une maladie lourde pour eux
c'est la mort assurée ce qui est pas
vrai du tout les séances sont
personnalisées en fonction des besoins
et de l'état physique du patient mais en
moyenne il faut compter une à deux
séances par semaine il s'agit d'un
accompagnement psychologique mais pas
seulement j'estime que le corporel a une
son importance donc une séance va durer
à peu près 1 heure ça peut durer à peu
près 20 25 minutes un quart d'heure
l'échange et après il va avoir une
séance de massothérapie où je vais
appuyer sur les points de tension où je
vais dénouer et cetera ou une
réflexologie tout dépend le le ressenti
que j'ai et les attentes du patient la
séance se conclut généralement par un
nouvel
échange le problème c'est que ces soins
de support restent encore un luxe il
faut compter entre 50 et 100 € la séance
et aucun remboursement n'est prévu
d'après le thérapeute même si ces soins
commencent à se développer depuis 2 ou 3
ans cela reste encore insuffisant ça
demande pas du matériel cher ça demande
de l'humain avec des connaissances sur
l'oncologie pour adapter des soins par
rapport à des pathologies et bah faut
former les gens et il faut rémunérer les
gens pour le moment les proxyologues
exercent grâce aux bouches à oreilles
mais aussi grâce aux praticiens et
jeunes oncologu qui les recommande
d'après le thérapeute aujourd'hui 60 %
des personnes atteintes du cancer ont
des eu recours à des soins de support en
complément de leur traitement
principal 60e anniversaire de la fin de
la guerre d'Indochine cette année en
souvenir des morts pour la France une
exposition vient de retracer le conflit
10 ans de combat la défaite de di
bienfou en 54 RAC compé à travers des
livres des objets et un film c'était à
Versailles il y a encore quelques
jours la guerre d'Indochine il y était
lors du conflit Gilbert re dirigeait un
commando de 30 vietnamiens notre mission
surtout d'aller au renseignement chez
l'ennemi nous étions habillés comme eux
comme les
viettes et bon on faisait la Guera la
Guer quoi si vous voulez il est des
anniversaires dont on se souvient moins
que d'autres c'est le cas pour la guerre
d'Indochine qui fête cette année ses 60
ans Alors pour y remédier la ville de
versaill a consacré une exposition à ce
conflit ignoré et cela tombe bien le
public est av de connaissance c'estire
de qui est rarement évoqué et si c'était
l'occasion de de l'aborder de façon très
précise et complète les panneaux
concernant le maréchal de Lat sont très
bien fait les panneaux plus spécifiques
sur la le conflit d'indchine aussi sont
très bien faits j'apprécie beaucoup
souvent comparé à la guerre d'Algérie
mais beaucoup moins relaté dans les
livres d'histoire le conflit en
indochchine a pourtant fait des dizaines
de milliers de morts 100000 morts dans
29000 français géré deessche et 47000
d'origine vietnamienne 76000 oubliés
pour une raison bien
particulière c'est une guerre qui a été
faite que par des engagés volontaires et
non pas le contingent comme la Gard
d'Algérie donc moins de familles ont été
impliqué que lors de la Guer d'Algérie
en plus d'un rappel historique de la
colonisation à l'indépendance
indochchinoise l'exposition a proposé
des documents d'époque des films et des
souvenirs étonnants comme le sable de di
bienfou et de la baé d' long une façon
vivace et concrète de perpétrer le
souvenir et d'apprendre aux jeunes ce
qu'on ne leur enseigne pas ou peu à
l'école fin de ce journal prochaine
édition demain même heure je vous
retrouve d'ici là à 18h30 19h30 et 23h
ce mardi soir pour le 78 politique
consacré aux européennes quatre
candidats en plateau pour débattre le
scrutin se déroulera le 25 mai bonne
[Musique]
soirée